I am wearing my leather jacket like some
kind of super fan I love it can we talk
about where we are today what we're what
we're doing yeah we are ahead Jessica
Jones favorite dive bar
this is Rudy's she comes here a lot here
shot here of three or four times in the
series from huh I know you are it's not
exactly a secret so you know I can break
your face I'm noticing a new character
in the scene today man Hawker is a new
addition to our cast this year and he's
a fantastic actor and he plays a sort of
new love interest for Jessica okay cuz
he asked me left off you know she was
kind of getting with the landlord
yeah landlord didn't work out didn't
work out very but yeah he was a nice guy
I think that was the problem
yeah you know a little too little too
awful to be the nice guy gets a little
rough around the edges a night at home
will be here's another drank well season
one is about you know Jessica facing her
demon season two about kind of piecing
together her past what is season three
about what's the theme here yes season
three em really dives into the
friendship between Jessica and Trish and
deals with the aftermath of season two
or she shot Jessica's mother yeah how do
you come back from that yeah I don't
know Wow
so that's what we're doing this season
yeah I'd love to get a super close-up on
her - in this season you actually direct
an episode I did how did you know
following all those directors kind of
paved the way for I learned so much from
them and they were all so generous with
me I got on the phone with almost all of
them before you know I was always like
strategizing how I was gonna let that I
was gonna convince them to let me direct
hmm and they were also great and always
giving me little tips and and and weighs
in and they were they were so great
it was really good so this this is
something you wanted to do and you can
forever
I get like showing up with my list of
other actors who are on shows the number
one on the call sheet and what episodes
they directed like it's difficult when
you're the title character the show
you're in a lot of it so it's it's a lot
of work so um I just kept showing up
like well Bryan Cranston did these
episodes and Jason Jason Bateman did
these episodes of Ozarks I just kept
showing up with my list and finally they
said yes yes it was kind of like a very
natural progression for me and it felt
really fun really celebratory because
these are my people I've been working
with them for four years so good I need
to collaborate with this crew and cast I
love so much in this new way was really
it was really a thrill we had a great
time and you know I know the cast so
well I know Rachel like she's one of my
best friends I know it she's really
great at and could always push her and
and you have a shorthand with with with
the actors that you know so well right
but isn't something you're like oh yeah
I definitely wanna do that oh absolutely
are you kidding everybody's got a story
a beginning
a middle and end
[Music]
[Music]